me
[Music]
the Grammys may have been jam-packed
with memorable moments but what you
didn't see on TV was just as
entertaining the room is is this energy
that
almost feels like too magical for me to
kind of take any responsibility for like
Taylor's Swift and Harry Styles big
reunion
[Music]
yep that's Taylor walking over to
Harry's table during Steve Lacy's
performance of bad habits the ex is
hugged chatted for a bit and according
to an eyewitness looked super friendly
showing there's no bad blood between
them
[Music]
in fact a source tells E.T Taylor and
Harry have no issues Taylor thinks he's
a talented artist and has nothing but
respect for him and she proved it
earlier in the night giving Harry a
standing ovation following his win for
best pop vocal album for Harry's house
this album from start to finish has been
the greatest experience of my life and
when Harry took the stage to perform his
hit track as it was
Taylor was on her feet dancing her heart
out
so naturally when Harry won album of the
Year Taylor was again cheering him on
Harry and Taylor have a long history
they briefly dated back in 2012 and
split after only a few months together
and though their courtship was brief
fans theorized that they both penned
songs about each other Harry's 2017
track two ghosts is thought to be about
the blank space singer
[Music]
and Taylor's 2014 hit style is rumored
to be inspired by you know Harry Styles
[Music]
and why did you name it
style because the hook is we never go
out of style and while the two have
never confirmed whom those songs are
about back in 2014 Harry said it's
flattering to have Tunes written about
him Taylor Swift written some songs
about you it seems like does it feel odd
when people write songs about you and
always are you okay I mean I think like
we always say that we write from
personal experience I think everyone
does so it'd be hypocritical of us to be
like oh you can't write songs and she's
really good so they're good songs our
source of firms that Taylor's moved on
and is very happy in her relationship
with Joe Alwyn adding that things are
peaceful and good between Taylor and
Harry so seems safe to say their
relationship has come a long way since
they're split and we stand these
friendly and supportive exes
[Music]
okay